Well, China's communist government
isn't laughing after a comedian
made a joke, loosely referencing
an Army slogan.
The performer known as House
is being investigated
and he has apologized
and he's canceled his shows.
His entertainment firm
has also said it sorry.
And it's being fined some $2 million
or this over a joke about dogs
chasing squirrels
and the use of a slogan,
fine style of work
capable of winning battles.
But it didn't stop there.
Police arrested a woman Tuesday
for questioning on social media,
why House was being punished
For more on all of this, CNN's Kristie
Lu Stout joins us live from Hong Kong.
Good to have you with us.
Kristie,
so it's certainly not an easy place
to be a comedian
The communist government
taking swift action.
Yeah.
You know, comedy
apparently is a high risk endeavor
in China under Xi Jinping.
Let's tell you what happened
and led to this crackdown.
It was during this
standup set that took place
in Beijing on Saturday, a Chinese comic
known as House.
His name in Mandarin is Li Hao. Sure.
Seen on your screen there.
He was riffing on this eight word
military slogan,
a slogan that's been used by the Chinese
leader, Xi Jinping.
He was making a joke
about watching his two rescue dogs
chase a squirrel.
And it reminded him of the slogan
that she used to comment on
and praise the work ethic of the play.
The joke went online, it went viral.
And then on Wednesday,
the Beijing police launched
an investigation.
Authorities,
they also fined the company
that represents Li nearly 2 million U.S.
dollars.
We heard this
from the Beijing Municipal
Bureau of Culture and Tourism
to bring up the statement for you
said, quote,
We will never allow any company
or individual
to wantonly slander
the glorious image
of the People's
Liberation Army
on the stage
in the Chinese capital, unquote.
The bureau
also said that the company
would never be allowed to stage
any feature shows in Beijing.
The company,
which had already issued an apology,
also fired the comedian.
The comedian has apologized profusely
on his Sina Weibo page on social media.
He canceled those performances,
too, in his words,
quote, deeply reflect
and reeducate myself.
Now it is come to this because in China,
insults against the military are illegal.
It was a few years ago
in 20, 21
that was when China passed a law banning
slander, insults
against military personnel
and on social media
for the last few days.
There are netizens who have been praising
this government decision.
They said, look, the joke
crossed the line.
It was an insult to soldiers.
But there were others that dispute that.
And they are fearing a wider crackdown.
On comedy in China.
And it's very easy to see why
because this week
a woman in northeastern China
was detained by police
after defending the comedian
and what he said on social media.
Back to you, Linda.
All right, Kristie
Lu Stout for us in Hong Kong.
Good to have you with us. Thank you.
Thank you.